but when we talk about mental
instability here in the United States we
cannot overlook the President of the
United States George Conway the husband
of white house councilor Kellyanne
Conway repeatedly warned us on Wednesday
in a very long Twitter screed that we
have got to do something about the
President of the United States and he
wasn't saying it to be funny he wasn't
saying it to be mocking and I don't say
these things that way either he's saying
them because clearly Donald Trump has
some kind of pathology that needs to be
thoroughly vetted and looked into that's
what George Conway was warning us about
and here's why
he went into this he said when you look
at the the Tim Appel lie
you know Trump first comes out says no I
said Tim Cook Apple I just said cook
really fast and you couldn't hear it
and then it was no I was saying Tim
Apple I just said it really fast to save
time the like eped changing but why did
the lie exist in the first place you
know it would have been a quick two
second funny goof that people would have
moved on from half an hour later but he
kept it alive because he couldn't keep
his story straight because of the
massive amount of narcissism that he has
for himself
that he had to try to fix it but he
doesn't know how to not lie and that's
why the like eped changing nothing about
it makes sense and that's what George
Conway was telling us in his you know
Twitter diatribe it doesn't make sense a
normal person wouldn't do this but a
normal person also doesn't have access
to nuclear codes or control the entire
military or control an entire branch of
government and Trump does and we have to
take this seriously because it's not
just that one lie it's not just the one
lie before that it's all of them taken
together we have to do something we have
a 25th amendment for a reason we just
need a Senate
enough courage to invoke it I'm fair and
cousins and for David Pakman we'll be
right back
one of today's sponsors is privacy calm
slash Pakman this is a free service that
I've actually been using myself for a
while now and I love it you just take a
few seconds to link your debit card or
bank account to privacy coms mobile app
or browser extension for Firefox and
Chrome and what that does is allow you
to instantly create virtual credit cards
that are linked to your bank account so
that you're not actually putting your
real debit card number on the Internet
and you use these virtual credit card
numbers to buy things online and with
one click of a button you have the
ability to create multiple virtual cards
delete cards freeze and unfreeze cards
you can put a limit on a card so a
company won't be able to charge you more
than you actually want them to and it
protects you from being hacked it
protects you from companies being hacked
which we've been talking about for a
while on the program and it's perfect
for signing up for free trial somewhere
if you don't want your real credit card
number to be exposed and on file and
their app and browser extension let you
autofill the virtual credit card number
into the credit card field when you're
buying things online there are a ton of
different advantages to shopping and
paying bills with a system like this
everything is totally secure and
encrypted and in some situations you can
earn 5% cash back on your purchases it's
all completely free all you have to do
is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
everybody in our audience who signs up
gets 5 dollars towards your first
purchase when you sign up using that
link below